[dramatic music]
MORGAN FREEMAN (VOICEOVER):
I'm about to have
an audience with a
living embodiment
of the Hindu god, Taleju.
My hope is that their Kumari
remains expressionless.
Even the hint of a smile is
said to bring misfortune.
[mystical music]
MORGAN FREEMAN: She didn't--
she didn't smile.
As a matter of fact, she didn't
have an expression at all.
MAN: OK.
So that's good for me, right?
MAN: That's a good thing.
That's a good thing.
MORGAN FREEMAN: All right.
And I also noticed that her
feet were up on a little--
a little platform.
MAN: Pedestal, yes.
So while she is the Kumari,
she should not touch the Earth.
And so she will
be carried around.
MORGAN FREEMAN: I see.
OK.
MAN: And so she gets carried
around in a palanquin--
MORGAN FREEMAN: Yeah.
MAN: --even when she
has to go to festivals
and to attend to other
rituals in the city.
MORGAN FREEMAN (VOICEOVER):
This royal treatment
isn't required merely out
of respect for the divine.
It avoids her receiving
cuts to her feet.
If she bleeds, she
ceases to be a goddess.
Of course, that day can
only be put off so long.
With the onset of
puberty, this young girl
must return to a way of life
that may now be alien to her.
It seemed like this would be
kind of a rough deal for a kid.
It is a rough deal for a kid.
But I think in this part
of the world, you know,
we are constantly
reminded about our duty.
Yes.
MAN: And so in the
years to come then
people take great
pride in the fact
that she was able to
serve our community
by taking on this duty.
MORGAN FREEMAN: And
after she's no longer a--
MAN: Right.
--goddess, what is she?
You know, once
she reaches puberty,
then the community begins to
search for a second child who
will replace her.
She enters the regular
family and I think--
She becomes just a regular--
A regular girl.
Got it.